انا بس بنوه على نقطه انه لما حكينا في
البدايه انك سالتني اذا في حضارات في
المملكه المملكه العربيه السعوديه الى
الان في اكتشاف موقعين غيرت مجرى تاريخ
واكتشافات العصر الحجري الحديث من ضمنها
موقعين الموقع الاول اللي هو زي ما ذكرت
حضاره المقر قبل حضاره المقر واكتشافها
كان اقدم استئناس للخيول ينتبه لكازاخستان
اللي هو 5000 قبل الميلاد بعد اكتشاف
حضاره المقر من 9000 في العشره الاف سنه
قبل الميلاد طلع هناك اقدم استئناس للخيول
فمن ضمنها كانوا حتى كانت الطبيعه لما
درسوا المنطقه وشافوا السكان وطبيعتها
عثروا على تمثيل الكلاب السلوقي للصيد
الصقور زي حياتنا اللي قلقانه يعني احنا
نمارسها مثلا استئناس التماثيل للخيول من
مصنوعه من الحجر في وادي الدواسر يعني هذه
بفعل التنقيب انتجت لنا نتيجه غيرت
السرديه التاريخيه عن موضوع مثلا استئناس
الخيول كان المعتاد انه قال انها استغنست
في كازاخستان قبل 5000 سنه طلع في فرق
4000 سنه ومش في كازاخستان في وادي
الدواسر في علم الاثر لما تكتشف حضاره
الاولى من نوعه تسميها على الموقع عشان
كذا سميت حضاره المقر وفي كمان موقع مهم
لنفس الفتره الحجريه في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه اللي هو اكتشاف
نقش الجمل اللي على الجبل